plus télé que les smartphones parce que
tu regarde à la télé de temps en temps
lille 9 45 heures mais rarement je suive
de temps en temps je re enfin un peu
tout le temps mais je regarde des gens
qui parlent de l'actualité puis si je
doute sur quelques sur quelque chose je
vais vérifier sur sur d'autres sites
il n'y a ni l'autre donc toi c'est
plutôt youtube ou des choses comme ça
moi et je suis pas sur facebook qu'ils
allaient journal papier
enfin les journaux papier à part des
magazines de sciences au prince où
comment tu t'es sûr que ce que tu dis
est vrai je vérifie sur différents si
c'est si au bout d'un moment c'est
récurrent je peux considérer que c'est
vrai parce que tu as retenu des choses
dans l'actualité dernièrement la
rencontre avec donald trump et kim
jong-un et s'attendent à entendu parler
par internet pour par internet et à la
télé ensuite